وفي ردود الفعل الدوليه على التطورات في
السودان قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انطوني بلينكن ان شعب السودان يريد عوده
الجيش الى تكناته ويريد الديمقراطيه معربا
عن قلقه من استمرار القتال هنا
عبرنا عن قلقنا بشان الاقتتال في السودان
الذي يهدد امن المدنيين
وتبادلنا الاراء بشان الطرق الكفيله بضمان
امن السودانيين والاجانب بما في ذلك
مواطنون الامريكيون والبريطانيون وتبادل
الراي حول مواقف حلفائنا في المجتمع
الدولي
نود ان يعود الحوار لوضع السوداني على
الطريق الصحيح للسلام لان السودانيين
يريدون الحكم المدني والديمقراطيه نتواصل
مع سفاراتنا في الجهات المعنيه ومع
مواطنينا للحفاظ على امنهم وسلامتهم
الامريكيه في الخرطوم قد قالت انها تواصل
مراقبه الوضع في الخرطوم والمناطق المحيطه
بها عن كتب وحثت السفاره مواطنيها على
البقاء في منازلهم حتى اشعار اخر واكدت
انه لا توجد اي خطط لاجلاء الامريكيين في
الوقت الحالي وانها ستعلن ذلك اذا ما اصبح
اجلاء المواطنين ضروريا
كما اعرب بيان صادر عن مجلس الامن الدولي
عن القلق العميق لدى اعضاء المجلس ازاء
الاشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريعه كما اعرب البيان عن اسف
اعضاء المجلس للخسائر في الارواح
والاصابات في صفوف المدنيين وحثت الدول
الاعضاء في مجلس الامن اطرف النزاع على
وقف الاعمال العدائيه فورا واستعاده الامن
كما دعت جميع الاطراف للعوده الى الحوار
لحل الازمه الحاليه في السودان وشددت
الدول الاعضاء في مجلس الامن على ضروره
مواصله اتاحه الدعم الانساني وضمان امني
موظفي الامم المتحده وعلمت الجزيره من
مصادرها في نيويورك ان مجلس الامن سيعقد
مشاوره مغلقه بشان السودان اليوم الاثنين
واضافت المصادر ان اللقاء يعقد بطلب من
بريطانيا